I mean constant that's how you learn
right and what's nice about Silicon
Valley is that it rewards that well now
let me take that back it doesn't reward
that it tolerates it more than large
enterprise where mistakes can be
career-ending in a really bad company
where they you know where it's a fear
typically a corporation that's run on
fear versus encouragement and and sticks
rather than carrots tends to be an
environment where mistakes are not
tolerated and then no innovation happens
and so Silicon Valley is the opposite it
encourage you to take risks and you know
entrepreneurs are not rational business
people I mean if you look at the risk
and reward curves we're way out here
we're taking a lot of risk for in the
hopes of a lot of reward but it's not
really rational you actually most
business people are much closer to the
the origin there where there's you know
some risk and some reward but not the
kind of risk that on Perez take so you
know the mistakes I've made in taking
those risks have been numerous and you
know there are you know wine shop or
obviously we were burning three million
dollars a month and before we even had
customers and that was you know the dog
food that everybody was eating back in
or the kool-aid that everybody's
drinking was you know build these build
it it's a land grab and the everyone
believed that it was the internet was
land grabbing had to build this thing we
built a 20,000 order a day pick pack
center to automatically fulfill wine and
Pat you know with it was a thing of
beauty built it from Greenfield to full
production in six months had 15 bays for
big ups trucks to back up into and you
know it never got to ship much wine and
you know it did actually those assets
were restarted by kleiner in a new
company called new vine logistics which
did ship wine in the back end for winery
clubs and what have you
it it was never never the opportunity
that we all believed it would be and you
know other mistakes I mean you make
hiring mistakes you make strategic
mistakes you I had an opportunity to
merge with a company earlier wine wine
choppers history that I did pursue
hindsight is twenty-twenty I'm sure to
pursuit it but you know each time you
get smarter and the other thing you
learn to do is you don't fret over your
mistakes you just interest instantly
correct and move on you make a bad hire
you got to make the decision to say
listen this isn't right it's not working
out and you cut and run in you and hire
someone else so you know as long as you
can act decisively you can undo the
effects of bad decisions but i think we
all make bad decisions the fact is if
you've never made any bad decisions you
probably weren't taking any risks
yeah I'm fundraising is hard right now
angels have their personal net worth's
have been depleted in some cases not
depleted but certainly reduce for their
less willing to take risks the VCS some
VCS have had trouble closing new funds I
mean the top pcs have money to spend and
there's plenty of money that's being
spent and invested the way I think of it
is well in terms of the stages it will
almost always is going to be credit card
debt and friends and family initially
it's very rare that you're going to go
right out of whatever your ideas and pop
into kleiner perkins and they're going
to write you a check you're going to
have to prove something before you can
typically raise money from a VC and the
four areas that you they look at there's
four areas of risk and investing is all
about you know risk versus reward so
they want as least as little risk for
the most rewards so they're going to try
and reduce that risk so there's
management risk market risk financial
risk and technology risk so management
risk if you've never run a company
before you'll do much better going in to
pitch a VC if you've already got two or
three season people who have run the
types of functions you need them to run
and and done it successfully on your
team so that reduces management risk you
know people in the company who've done
it before you don't have to do all four
of these but you have to you know
typically hit depending on the investing
climate to 24 so the market risk is is
there a market for your product what's
the competitive landscape is it you know
a billion dollar opportunity cuz VCS
typically they want to see at least a
billion dollar Dust Bowl market that
doesn't mean you can't start a company
if it doesn't have an addressable market
of a billion dollars it just means it's
probably not a VC play it's probably a
different type of business since you
don't have to attract venture to build a
great business as many people know the
third one was financial risk which is
their business model can you actually
make money I
you know is there a way for this
business to sustain itself and be
profitable and the fourth is technology
risk which if your company involves some
kind of new technology or new thing have
you built one and proven that it can be
done and you know during the bubble days
like in in 1998-99 when it was really
crazy you could probably only have to
tick off one of those boxes to get VC
funding now you probably need to tick
off pretty probably all for maybe three
and you know and market and mitigating
market risk means having paying
customers right so that's not always the
case certainly in the past few years
there's been a rush of money sent into
social media stuff but you know the more
that you can sort of address those four
issues and do it in a very convincing
way through data through you know beta
customers through letters of intent
whatever you can do to sort of increase
the likelihood that you're going to be
able to execute is going to improve your
chances of getting funded